Well.
It was working.
Now we got it.
Were you able to pull up the first deck?
There we go. Thanks.
Oh.
This is the right one. Okay.
All right. Welcome, everyone. I think we're going to get started.
Just to give a little bit of housekeeping as you guys file in,
we're going to have
three presentations,
and they'll be 20 minutes, and then we'll have Q&A after each
section. You can come up to the mics when you have your questions.
And then
I'll give a brief introduction now,
and then we'll kick off with Dr. Ellison.
So my name is Sarathcnan Alapati, I'm an investigator at Sloan Kettering in New
York,
and the title of this entire session is Resistance to
Antibody-Drug Conjugates.
For those of you who have been at the meeting the whole time and walked around the
posters and sort of seen some of the talks, there have been a
lot of new antibody drug conjugates.
It's almost breathtaking how much diversity there are of
new antibody drug conjugates. And that sort of begs the question, why do
we have a session dedicated to resistance to antibody drug conjugates?
There are all these new ones,
and which
antibody drug conjugates, when there are so many, which ones should we be talking
about resistance to?
And so one of the things I want to
first start off by saying is we're going to focus really on antibody drug
conjugates that work. So shown here
is the data from enfortumab vedotin
in comparison to conventional chemotherapy in bladder cancer,
showing the incredible efficacy of this now standard of care
regimen. We are interested in studying resistance to drugs like this that
work,
and we're decidedly not going to spend a lot of time talking about resistance
to drugs that didn't make it, such as Mylotarg
or the CD44 and 56 ADCs. And
that's really by design. I think we can learn quite a lot
by studying resistance to drugs that work.
So why study resistance to drugs that work?
First of all, I think we learn in general about any drug that
works. We learn in general a lot about the vulnerabilities
of the cancer that we've studied. We've just applied an incredible selective
pressure. It has culled the tumor, it has shaped the
evolution of that tumor, and what we get out on the back end of resistance tells
us a lot about the underlying biology and plasticity of that
cancer. So as a very different example with
hormone therapy and breast cancer that I've studied for a long time, we learned
a great deal by studying resistance to hormone therapy.
We learned about sets of tumors that were so addicted to
estrogen receptor that they mutated the estrogen receptor at resistance.
Others, however, that changed their biology or
unlocked a biology that was dependent on MAP kinase signaling.
So we learned a lot about the way that the cancer evolves and some
underlying dependencies. Secondly, we learn a lot about the
drugs that we are giving. By
studying resistance, we learn about what aspect of the drug was really pivotal to
the efficacy of the drug. These are complex drugs, antibody drug conjugates,
with interesting chemistry around the linkers, around the types
of payloads,
specific aspects of the payloads, the different antibodies themselves.
What aspect of that was most important becomes unveiled when we study
resistance, because that pressure point sort of tells
us why did it work in the first place? How did the cancer adapt?
Third, of course, it tells us about potential biomarkers to refine how
we give these drugs. If
there are groups of tumors that don't respond
in terms of intrinsic resistance, we understand those are ones we should
exclude from future therapy and give some of these new ADCs to.
And then finally, I think we've seen this at this meeting, of course,
with many of the RAS drugs. As we understand resistance, it allows us to
develop better
ADCs. If we understand the pressure points, if we understand what failed,
we can come in with second generation and third generation
drugs.
So with that backdrop, we're going to have three
presentations on antibody drug conjugate resistance, and
I'll invite to the podium Dr. Leif Ellison from Mass General
Hospital to talk about mechanisms of ADC resistance
informing novel combination therapy strategies.
Thank you, Sarath, and thanks to the organizers for the opportunity to
speak.Let's see. What do I click here to
get my presentation?
There it is. Thank you. So today,
as Sirat had mentioned, I want to talk about antibody drug conjugates,
resistance, and implications for ongoing therapeutic
combination approaches and future approaches.
I'll start with some data about target-mediated and
payload-mediated resistance. Then we'll move on to
pathways that we might be able to target to enhance
sensitivity. And finally, we'll step back and take a more
holistic view of the tumor as a whole in thinking about how
the ADC works in the tumor microenvironment and what opportunities
might be there.
These are my disclosures. Much of the data that I'll be telling you
about is related to our work and the work in our group
on cetuximab gevیتicin, which I'll refer to as SG.
The trade name is Trodelvy, which is in many ways a paradigm ADC
approved for triple-negative and HR-positive breast cancer.
Since I'm the first ADC talk in the session, I'll go over the
major features. So SG, an antibody targeting
the cell surface protein Trop-2. The payload
is a topoisomerase 1 inhibitor, SN-38,
and linked via a cleavable and
hydrolyzable linker.
So SG first demonstrated efficacy most
notably in advanced triple-negative breast cancer, and this is
data from the Phase III ASCENT trial, where you can see that for
patients with heavily pretreated TNBC, that SG
nearly doubled overall survival compared to physician's choice
chemotherapy.
So a highly active agent, in many ways transformative for these
patients, but only a response rate of 30%.
So when we think about what are the hypothesized proposed
mechanisms of ADCs and how they relate to resistance, we
believe that ADCs function generally by engaging to the target on
the cell surface. They're then internalized and through endolysosomal
processing, end up fused with the lysosome, where they're degraded,
releasing payload within the cell for cytotoxicity.
That payload, in some cases, as with SG, is cell permeable
and therefore can extrude to the microenvironment and
kill neighboring cells, a so-called bystander effect for even
target-negative neighboring cells.
With an ADC with a relatively labile linker like SG, payload can be
released even in the microenvironment without internalization,
leading to a kind of outside bystander
effect. So when we think about these mechanisms, there's data
at each of these steps that's related to resistance.
So obviously expression of the target can be important.
Pathways for internalization and trafficking are showing up now when we look at
resistance pathways. Lysosomal processing, a competent lysosome, for
example, is important. Payload sensitivity and intrinsic sensitivity of
the tumor cells and the bystander effect I talked about.
And then what I'll come to at the end is findings from
clinical trials that we're being able to unveil the immune microenvironment
that's relevant to therapy and combinations.
So if we think about first the target,
particularly for the ADCs approved in breast cancer, which target either
Trop-2 or HER2,
target level has been only poorly predictive of
response to these drugs. This is again the Phase III ASCENT
trial where we're looking at progression-free survival by tertiles of Trop-2
expression for the ADC versus chemotherapy.
And what you see is there's only a rough correlation between Trop-2 expression
and PFS on the ADC, but in each case, it's
better than chemotherapy,
and this is why we do not select based on expression for clinical
use of SG.
Now we wanted to look more
broadly in patients at mechanisms of resistance, particularly in the
acquired resistance setting. And so we study
a group of patients who had been treated with advanced triple-negative breast
cancer with SG as a single agent. And then a subset
of patients who progressed went on to
rapid autopsy ultimately, and we were able to do biopsies of multiple
lesions, whole exome sequencing, and then look at
pre-treatment versus post-treatment tumor changes and mechanisms of resistance in
that setting.
And what we found is that a number of lesions, all the
lesions above the diaphragm harbored an acquired mutation in Trop-2,
a missense mutation, and all the lesions below the diaphragm, in this case,
harbored mutations in topoisomerase 1.
This was immediately of interest because the Topo1 E418K mutation in
particular was one that had never been seen in humans but was actually described
many years ago in cell lines that were exposed to high levels of a Topo1 inhibitor,
and you could actually elicit this mutation, which was proven to be a
resistance mechanism. The Trop-2 mutation was
novel, but we went on to show in this paper we published five years ago
that this interesting Trop-2 mutation didn't affect the protein
expression or its stability, but what it did was shuttle the protein off the
cell surface. Here you can see immunofluorescence confocal microscopy
where wild-type Trop-2 on the tumor cell surface beautifully decorating
the cell membrane. But the
missense mutant Trop-2 entirely internal, and we could show in
models that if you put in wild-type Trop-2, you can convey high sensitivity
to SG. If you put in the mutantThey remain
entirely resistant. So this is a very interesting case,
but of course, when you think about it, the idea that even in an individual patient
you might have resistance based on both the target and the payload is
a cautionary tale for the use of one ADC after another, which might be
related in target or payload. Rachel Abelman
presented this data a couple of years ago at San Antonio
Breast, showing that the time to progression on average
for TNBC patients and patients with HR positive HER2 Negative disease
is substantially shorter on the second ADC, and it
didn't matter which approved ADC you used first.
It didn't matter the sequence or the timing between the
first one and the second one, substantially shorter progression-free
survival. Numbers were small, but this was particularly true
if the second ADC had the same payload, underscoring
an important role for payload-associated resistance in
the setting of progression on SG. We
wanted to look at that more broadly in a case series, and in this
case, through cell-free DNA analysis.
And so we showed in this paper published last year that a number
of patients actually harbored acquired TOP1
mutations. And again, some of them, like R364H, had been previously
described in cell lines as bona fide resistance mutations.
We went on to show that these mutations, by and large, have the
hallmarks of bona fide TOP1 resistance mutations.
This is the crystal structure of TOP1 in blue and DNA in
green. TOP1 engages directly with DNA.
The drug works by intercalating between the protein and the DNA.
The resistance mutations are adjacent to the DNA protein interface, and they
affect that interface so that the protein cannot intercalate.
We then went on to show that indeed, if you track these in the blood by
quantitative ddPCR, that the emergence of these
TOP1 mutations were a harbinger of progression.
So stepping back from this, clearly we need to know at
the level of individual patients what might be the resistance mechanism.
If it's clearly payload dependent, you're going to want to switch payload in your
next ADC. If it's target dependent, conversely, you might want to
switch the target.
So we wanted to look in the lab more broadly at these tumor intrinsic mechanisms.
We've done many CRISPR screens over the years.
This was actually, I think, the first one we've done, probably the most
informative. You can see this is the volcano plot.
Each dot represents a gene. On the left, genes whose knockout sensitizes to SG
and TNBC cells, on the right, those whose knockout induces resistance.
A lot of the players we'd want to see are there, so replication associated repair,
homologous recombination, knockout induced sensitivity, knockout of
TOP1, which is a great positive control.
We know that TOP1 loss, because the drug has to bind to it to work, induces
resistance. From a targeting point of view, the PARP pathway looked quite
intriguing. Loss of PARP1 caused sensitivity.
Conversely, loss of the glycohydrolase PARG that opposes PARP1
induced resistance. And this was not a
surprise. It was known that indeed there's a strong interaction
between PARP inhibition and TOP1 inhibition.
And that is because, as I mentioned, the inhibitor works by intercalating between
TOP1 and DNA, and this complex,
called the TOP1 cleavage complex, where the DNA is cleaved, is
stabilized by the inhibitor and it ultimately breaks down a double-strand break,
leading to cell death. It turns out to clear this, it's a
PARP-dependent pathway where PAR must parlate TDP1, which
is the phosphodiesterase, to cleave the TOP1 off the DNA.
Ubiquitin proteasome pathway then degrades
TOP1. So if you inhibit PARP, you stabilize these
complexes. You have a lot of extra double-strand breaks, and ultimately, death.
So we went on to test clinically, as I'll show you, the PARP pathway.
But also note that there are a number of interesting
players that also mediate this TOP1cc
stabilization if they are inhibited.
Ubiquitin proteasome pathway, which has to degrade TOP1 itself on the
DNA, and then endonucleases that can cleave the DNA to
get rid of this TOP1cc and allow, again,
reassembling of the whole double-stranded DNA.
So
other potential options, including PARP, and we're looking at
those pre-clinically. One of the reasons being that because this
PARP1, TOP1 story had been around for a long time, a number of trials had used
systemic PARP1 and TOP1 inhibitors.
By and large, administered systemically, it's not really tolerable because there's
not a great therapeutic index. A lot of toxicity, particularly to blood
cells, so myelo suppression is a dose-limiting toxicity.
But we hypothesized, and this is work we did with Aditya Bardia, that
the ADC delivery might create a better therapeutic window.
And the hypothesis went like this, that because the ADC delivers higher
doses of the drug to tumor cells than normal cells, that might
create actually a temporal window whereby you could
give the drug, such as SG, and then you could wait.
Normal cells would clear the drug, tumor cells would still have drug still
around, and then come in with a PARP inhibitor and have more effective
and selective effect. We tested this in the laboratory.
If you look in the middle panel, this is in cases where we apply SG, we wash it
out, and then we apply the PARP inhibitor, in this case talazoparib.
And you can see that even though the drugs are not on the cell at the same time,
you actually get synergistic enhancement of
cytotoxicity. And we can see the biochemical hallmark of the
mechanism. As I mentioned, these are cell nuclei here in blue, and the
red is confocal microscopy showing us the stabilized TOP1 cleavage
complex. So when you treat with a drug, you get a stabilized
TOP1cc.Interestingly, once you wash it off, within 30 minutes,
the cell has resolved that, as I showed by all those PARP proteasome
pathways, and eliminated it. But if you put on the PARP inhibitor,
those are stabilized and ultimately leading to double-strand breaks and
cell death. Then together with Aditja, when he was in our
program, now the leader of breast program and translational research at UCLA,
we conducted a Phase 1b2 dose escalation expansion study.
In this case, we started with two cohorts, one a
concurrent dosing, and another one on a staggered dosing schedule
with SG days one and eight, starting the PARP inhibitor on day
15.
And
this slide summarizes some of the data from that trial.
And what we found was that the concurrent
administration was not tolerable from the point of view of
myelosuppression, similar to systemic TOP1/PARP1
administration. You can see that here with greater 71%
dose limiting toxicity and short progression-free survival here in
the swimmers plot. On the other hand, when we dosed
sequentially,
we were able to preserve some level of efficacy.
We have, I think, one patient still on treatment after more than five years,
and no dose-limiting toxicities.
So this is a first step. It was not a randomized trial, so we don't know
clearly about efficacy, but this concept is now going forward in
multiple different versions, and in other diseases
where one of the major advances that may make this even more
exciting as a regimen is the advent of PARP1 selective
inhibitors. The approved PARP1 inhibitors target PARP1 and 2.
Much of the myelosuppression from the combination comes from targeting stem cells,
which primarily express PARP2. So the idea with a
selective PARP1 inhibitor in combination could be more
tolerable, could be tolerable for concurrent dosing,
and allow us to push doses higher, and get efficacy from
this very mechanistically grounded combination.
And that's work going on in the lab, work that's going on in our breast
spore. And we and a lot of folks in the field are still
excited about this combination.
So now let's take a step back and we wanted to look holistically at the
tumors and particularly looking at de
novo resistance pathways. And so we
designed a series of preoperative neoadjuvant trials,
in this case using SG, the first of which led by
Laura Spring, where patients got preoperatively four
cycles of SG, followed by biopsy or surgical assessment of the
response. Because if it's important to prognosis in triple-negative breast cancer,
the primary endpoint with pathologic complete response, which was
30% to SG alone, and Laura published the results in
Annals a couple of years ago. From our point of view, we
were very pleased to be able to develop a strong translational backbone on this
study with pre-post treatment biopsies that we could do single-cell RNA-seq,
tumor
whole exome
sequencing, and then a multiplex spatial
immunofluorescence, and then really do an integrative analysis
to try to identify the features associated with
response and progression, in this case, really dividing
it primarily into those tumors that achieve pathologic complete
response versus those who didn't.
So here's a very busy slide with the single-cell
RNA-seq data. The UMAP is shown here on the left, and in the middle is all
the detailed cell annotation for all the cell types that we can see,
and then comparing path CR to non-path CR tumors.
The boxes indicate cell types that are significantly
associated with pathologic complete response in the cohort, red
showing positive association with path CR, blue showing negative
association with path CR, and then the box plots
quantitate that and show it at the level of individual specimens.
So what you can see is that
CD8 progenitor so-called TPECs cells are strongly
associated with response in the cohort, also associated with
chemotherapy response, one should say.
Also activated NK cells, perhaps interesting from
an ADCC/ADCP perspective
for an antibody drug conjugate. And then interestingly, from the
lack of response, myelosuppressive macrophages associated with
non-path CR. And of particular interest, which was a strong signal
throughout the study, was the role of the endothelium and
angiogenesis. So a particular subset of
angiogenic endothelial cells was quite significantly
associated with lack of pathologic response.
And then when we went to the spatial data, among the number one
individual cell types whose distribution and
abundance was associated with lack of response were CD31
positive endothelial cells. So a very strong signal in this
study for the endothelial compartment.
So because of the important role of T cells, we wanted to look into more detail
in those. And,
as you might guess, it was really cycling T cells,
CD8 T cells that were the hallmarks of pathologic complete
response. And you can see in a reclustering of the CD8 cells, the different
subtypes,
and here in the UMAP projection, the proliferating cells, more abundant, and here
in the violin plot,
clearly also shown in the spatial.
We were gratified that we were able to use different biopsies for spatial and a
single-cell RNA-seq, and to get the concordant results was quite satisfying, and
the spatial data is quantitative here.
So what we really wanted to do then was ask, well, what is the mechanism that leads
to these T cell microenvironmental features and the presence and
activation of the T cells? So we did a lot of correlation analysis and a lot of
data of pretreatment TNBC cells. And remarkably,
one of the number one associations was Trop-2, the target of the ADC
itself, and this is a cyber sort of inferred from
bulk RNA-seq data.Throughout breast cancer, the
blue boxes show a strong negative association between T cell
presence, activated T cell markers, and the abundance
of TROP2 in the tumor cell of these
breast cancers. So TROP2 inversely associated with an active
immune microenvironment. So we went on to study
the basis of this, and this paper was just published a couple of weeks
ago by Bogang Wu, a very talented postdoc who's now an independent investigator
at Mayo Clinic. And what we showed was that in the TNBCs,
TROP2 is strongly associated with tight junctions through
its physical interaction, you can see here on the right, with claudin-7.
And this was really reminiscent of the normal role of TROP2, which
is in the corneal epithelium, where it maintains tight junctions.
And if you have an inherited germline mutation in TROP2, you get corneal clouding
because of loss of those tight junctions.
Well, in TNBC, you see these tight junctions.
If you do a CRISPR knockout in these tumors in vivo, you see that strong
gene signature is associated with high TROP2 or tight junctions, and all the
signatures associated with loss of TROP2 are immune
infiltration. So how can we leverage this?
Here in the models, what Bogang did was he looked at targeting TROP2, not the
ADC, but TROP2 itself, and then activating the T cells with
anti-PD-1. And here's an example of one of the experiments
using doses where neither the TROP2 targeting or the anti-PD-1 alone
had any effect on tumor growth. But when you combine the anti-TROP2
with the anti-PD-1, you get a substantial attenuation of growth.
And even more interesting or satisfying was the effect on the
CD8 cells themselves. What we showed was that targeting
TROP2 alone recruited more CD8 cells but didn't change their
activation state. Targeting PD-1 increased the activation state but
didn't change the number of T cells.
And it was only when you had both more cells and activation that you could
actually see this
attenuation of tumor progression that we saw.
So
indeed, these results were later, shall we say,
consistent with Phase III data showing that the
addition of PD-1 checkpoint therapy with
pembrolizumab for first-line treatment of PD-L1-positive
patients with triple-negative breast cancer was superior to
chemotherapy plus anti-PD-1
in this setting. So, a combination that we believe is mechanism-based
both on the target TROP2 and the role of the microenvironment.
So finally, this is my last data slide, and I know my time is almost up.
So we want to do analysis of the interaction of different cell types,
here using an algorithm that's related to natural language processing.
And this is where we look at cell types that are in proximity,
spatial multicellular neighborhoods.
Because it's related to natural language, we call them topics.
And you can see all the different clusters of topics here.
And then in the forest plot, you can see their association with path CR or with
residual disease. For example, topic three, the CD8 cells, you can
see them here. This topic five, which is the endothelial
cells, you can see that down here in association with suppressive
macrophages. And then a really interesting subset are
what look like these quiescent cell clusters, small clusters of cells that are very
strong for TROP2 and also associated with the endothelium,
suggesting that probably there's crosstalk where the endothelium may shape
the quiescence of these cells, where they may promote hypoxic and
drug-resistant signatures. That's a hallmark of drug resistance in this setting.
So finally, just to summarize, we can see multiple ways to
intervene based on tumor intrinsic features, the payload
mechanism,
and the immune microenvironment targeting not only T cells, but
macrophages, and the vasculature.
And these are just some of the many different ideas that are coming forward through
these kinds of basic and translational studies. So thank you for attention.
I'm happy to take questions.
All right. Invite questions at the microphones, please.
Over here.
Hey, Leif. Great talk.
Here, this side, Leif.
Yes.
Did you ever look at the BRCA1 status in the patients who
had a resistance or response to the
govitican?
Yeah, it's a very good question, and there's a little bit of a mixed data on
SG as a single agent and BRCA status.
With larger numbers, you might be able to squint and see some more enhanced
responses, but somewhat variable.
And then similarly, in the PARP combination, we didn't see association so much
with BRCA status, and that relates to the fact that we
believe, and we think, that a lot of what PARP is doing is not, as I said, related
to its canonical role in complementing homologous recombination
deficiency, but its role in resolving these Topo1 cleavage
complexes.
Thanks.
Over on the left.
Thank you for the excellent presentation.
It's
very interesting to see that the consequential versus sequential treatment of SG
plus talaparatide, you get a significant difference in terms of the response.
Have you tried to look at the biomarkers, the circulating DNA or any other
biomarkers, and do you see any change in that with this treatment paradigm?
Excellent question, and I'll have to come back next year and tell you.
The good news is that we were able to collect pretreatment, post-treatment,
and sequential during treatment, and we literally have just submitted all
of that for sequencing for the cell-free DNA.
And so we're not only going to be able to look at what are the acquired mutations
that occur in that setting, but this idea that perhaps either the quantity or the
mutations emerging in the cell-free DNA are going to be harbingers of
progression. So we're very excited about that analysis.
Thank you.
Excuse me. On the left.
We'll go to the right and then the left.
Okay.
Oh, sorry. You're over here.
You first.
A curiosity,
cetuximab is an unstable ADC and releases
738 both in the circulation and in the tumor
microenvironment. So this is fine for killing
bystander T cells. Can that kill
also immune cells?
Can that tame the favorable impact
on the immune system?
Yeah, I think it's an excellent question that you're raising, and I think it's
always been a concern, right? The idea that will
bystander be better on the tumor, promoting more immunogenic cell
death, or will it have negative effects on the T cell microenvironment
through a cytotoxic effect on the T cells?
When we look at the post-treatment specimens, which I didn't have time to tell you
about from the preoperative study, there's a tremendous amount of
activation of the immune microenvironment post-treatment.
So I would say that it's not a strong attenuation.
And again, you have that bystander, which the more immunogenic cell death, that's
going to invigorate the immune response.
So like with many things with the ADCs, it's fairly empiric.
Okay.
And last question.
So,
very nice talk. It just got me thinking about
what percentage of your patients actually
develop mutations either in the TOPO1
isomerase gene or TROP2.
And related to that, Sasi G does have adverse
events, and I'm trying to figure out if, when we think about
mechanisms of resistance,
it really is talking about patients progressing.
So what percentage of patients actually progress because of dose
reductions and dose discontinuations or
off-tumor-based toxicities of these ADCs that we're
treating with as compared to actual
clinically meaningful mutations in TOPO1 or
TROP2?
Yeah, excellent question. So TROP2 mutations turn out to be
relatively rare. TOP1 mutations, more common,
and in particular in patients who have deep responses and then
progress. So there's really on target seems to be very potent resistance.
But we're still talking about probably 10% of patients might
have those mutations, maybe less.
And you raise a good point about the toxicities of SG.
And so oncologists who give SG
think of it much like they do chemotherapy, for better or worse.
And what I mean by that is it is true that SG has
significant toxicities. It's also true that those are the toxicities,
myelosuppression, diarrhea, others, that oncologists are
extremely
well trained and versed in managing with patients to get them
through. It's basically the toxicities that so much of the chemotherapy that we
give every day. And so we pay very careful
attention to that. But particularly with SG, it has
more chemo-like toxicities than other ADCs with more stable linkers, for
example.
Thank you.
All right. We're right at time, so let's again thank Dr. Ellison.
All right. I'm just going to invite now Dr.
Jonathan Chou from UCSF who will be presenting on tumor intrinsic and
extrinsic mechanisms of ADC resistance in bladder cancer.
Great. Thank you so much. Good afternoon, everyone.
I'd like to thank Siraj and the organizers for the invitation to come and speak to
you and share some of our lab's published and unpublished work looking at ADC
resistance mechanisms in bladder cancer.
And it is no easy order to follow Dr.
Ellison's talk, so I will try my best.
Here are my disclosures, none of which are relevant to the talk today.
So I wanted to just briefly introduce bladder cancer to this audience.
I think it's a tumor type that we don't hear that much about
typically at these large meetings.
Eighty-five thousand cases in the US with over half a million
cases in the world. Bladder cancer is a really interesting
tumor because the majority of patients who have
non-muscle invasive bladder cancer have this
superficial growing tumor in their bladders.
But unfortunately, 20% of patients have this muscle-invasive disease that grows
from the inner lining of the bladder and grows radially outward.
And this is the disease that ends up killing patients.
Unfortunately, even patients with localized disease end up
needing a lot of procedures. So it's actually one of the most expensive tumor types
to take care of because they need frequent urologic procedures, including
cystoscopies, as well as radiographic monitoring.
And while we use the term bladder cancer and urothelial carcinoma or
UC fairly synonymously, I think one of the really interesting parts of bladder
cancer is that it's actually a very heterogeneous disease.
And so while the predominant histology that the pathologist sees is
urothelial, there are all these different variant histologies, squamous,
sarcomatoid, plasmacytoid, small cell adenocarcinoma, et cetera,
making the treatment for bladder cancer as a single disease very challenging.
And we aren't quite there at the level that the breast cancer oncologists are.
We don't break up molecular subtypes into HR positive, HR
negative, and HER2 positive. And so we're still a little bit behind in terms of
molecular subtyping.
The final thing that I'll say about bladder cancer is that while the majority of
patients with urothelial carcinoma have lower tract disease that actually
starts, originates in the bladder, about 10 to 15% of patients actually
have urothelial carcinoma that's in the upper tract.So just to remember that
the urothelium actually starts all the way up here in the kidneys, in the renal
pelvis, lines the ureter. And so we extrapolate our
treatments for upper tract
patients from the lower tract regimens, even though we know that while they
share many molecular features, they're actually fairly distinct entities.
So historically, how have we treated bladder cancer?
I think
up until about 10, 15 years ago, we were really using cisplatin, which
of course we know generates DNA damage by binding to the DNA and generating these
bulky adducts. I think over the last 15 years, we've been really
fortunate. Bladder cancer's been a really exciting space, and in particularly
looking at surface protein targeting therapies, which are lab studies, which
include, of course, ADCs, the topic of this session today.
And many of these proteins are still yet undefined in many carcinomas.
And I've been really blown away walking through the posters yesterday
and today, just how many different targets there are, and what Siraj
kind of mentioned in one of his cartoons, like kind of pick what's in the
black box here. And also I think, thinking about the
biomarkers of response and resistance,
which certainly piggybacks off of one of the sessions that Dr.
Pistilli presented yesterday. For those who didn't get to make that talk, it
was really an excellent session. So
not only do we have single-pass transmembrane proteins, which has been the
predominant type of protein that we've been targeting, but we also know that we can
now target multi-pass transmembrane proteins as well as peptide MHC complexes, of
course. And of course, this is super interesting as an oncologist, right?
Because we can now, if we identify the correct surface protein, think about not
only imaging and localizing the disease, but also thinking about the
various types of therapies. Over the last 15 years or so,
we've seen an explosion of new therapies for bladder cancer.
And I think the thing that I want to point out is that every single one of these
therapies actually goes after a cell surface protein. Okay?
Whether it's our antibody drug conjugates that we're going to talk about today,
like EV, SG, that Dr. Allison just talked about, or HER2 targeting
therapies, whether it's checkpoint therapies like PD-1, PD-L1, which are also on
the surface of the cancer cells and the T-cells, or whether there are small
molecule kinase inhibitors like FGFR3 inhibitors.
Every single one of the new therapies in bladder cancer goes after a cell surface
protein. And so, of course, we're going to talk a little bit about EV, which is
a ADC that targets the surface protein nectin-4.
And in contrast to SG, which carries that topoisomerase
inhibitor, EV actually carries an MMAE molecule, which is a
microtubule stabilizing agent. And what I'll just say is
that as we think about resistance mechanisms, we have to also think about what our
toolbox is as oncologists. Now, I think it's a really exciting time to be in
medical oncology because we not only have naked antibodies, like our checkpoint
therapies, trastuzumab, et cetera, but we actually have a whole suite
of different tools now in our toolbox.
And just showing you a few of those, including ADCs,
radioligands, T-cell engagers, CARs, TCR therapies.
I think
really the sky is out there in terms of
thinking about all the ways to attack the cell surfaceome.
But I think as we are doing this, I think a number of key questions
emerge. And I think this talk really
piggybacks really nicely off of Leif's talk.
In thinking about target expression, and I'll probably argue a little bit
differently in terms of EV, what the role of target expression is.
So how do we deal with low or heterogeneous target expression?
If we can figure out how cells control the
expression of these targets, can we actually leverage that and turn up the volume
to enhance these responses? And what other cells or factors in the TME
might affect the response?
Okay, so this is the waterfall plot from the pivotal trial that Jonathan
Rosenberg and colleagues led. This is EV
monotherapy in a heavily pretreated metastatic bladder cancer
population. And what we saw from this trial that was published over six years ago,
seven years ago now, was that we saw an overall response rate of 45% with a
CR rate of 12% and an OS of 12 months.
This is in a patient population that otherwise would have a median overall
survival of about four to five months.
Now, in combination with pembrolizumab, we
now see that the new standard of care for treating frontline metastatic bladder
cancer patients is EV plus pembro.
And you can see the OS benefit nearly doubled from 16 months
to 31 and a half months.
So let's take a look at that data little bit more closely.
If we break up the patients between nectin-4
low on the left versus nectin-4 high expressing patients on the
right, what you'll first see is that EVp beats out
chemotherapy. Absolutely. You see that top line of
EVP over the chemo line. But if you actually take a look a little bit
more closely at this data here, what you'll see is that the median PFS in the low
cohort is 10.4 months compared to about 15 months.
So that's a 50% increase, a five-month increase in PFS
if you have a nectin-4 high expressing tumor.
And if you actually take a look at the OS benefit across these different
subtypes, now breaking it up into thirds, so H scores less than
150, between 150 and 225, and over 225, what you'll see
is that the OS actually tracks very nicely from 18.4
months in the low, 25.4 months in the medium, and 31 and a half
months in the high, with the interval, the confidence interval shrinking
as you get to higher and higher, more homogeneous expression.
So we've wondered, we've taken a look at this data and we wondered, well, can you
actually convert these nectin-4 low tumors
into high tumors? And I'm not saying that these are necessarily primary
resistant patients, but they're just less sensitive than those who have high
tumors. And this, of course, has been seen in other studies.
This is actually data from Niklas Klemperer and Markus Eckstein in Germany, where
they showed actually that there's a subset of patients with bladder cancer as well
as breast cancer, about 15%, that actually have a chromosome 1 amplification,
which is where the PVRL gene, the gene that encodes for nectin-4, is located.
And in these subset of patients with the nectin-4 amplification, you actually
see beautiful membranous, homogenous staining of
nectin-4.As quantified here, and you can see that
the difference in survival is extreme, right?
So the patients who have nectin-4 amplifications are doing extraordinarily
better than those without the non-amplified tumors.
We've seen this now in our own UCSF cohort, as I think many other people in this
space have seen. This is actually data from my close friend and collaborator,
Dr. Carissa Chu, and our pathology colleague, Cornelia Ding, as well as
one of the senior scientists in Carissa's lab, Tamila Nechiporuk.
And what you can see is that, again, this homogeneous membranous staining in our
patients with complete responses to the EV monotherapy
compared to very heterogeneous staining in the
primary
or in the progressive disease patients.
So whether it's because it's very weak on the surface, whether it's because it's in
the cytoplasm, or whether it's because it's completely negative.
So here are the questions that we've been thinking about.
How do bladder cancer cells actually regulate nectin-4, and can we leverage those
mechanisms to essentially use some parlance from the immunotherapy literature?
Can we turn our cold nectin-4 tumors into hot nectin-4
tumors? And will this actually improve responses to the targeted therapy?
So we've known that
staining a TMA from Dr. Peter Black at UBC,
that nectin-4 expression is very heterogeneous in MIBC.
And if we take a look at the molecular subtypes of bladder cancer, what we've seen,
whether we look at the protein level or at the mRNA level, is that there's a
strong association between nectin-4 expression and these luminal
subtypes. Not surprising, right?
Many of our carcinoma tumor-associated antigens are
carcinoma antigens because they are expressed in well-differentiated
cells.
We can formally demonstrate this.
If you take a cell line that has high nectin-4 levels, you get rid of nectin-4,
you get resistance. Not surprising.
If you take a cell line that's negative in nectin-4 and you express nectin-4 in it,
you get exquisite sensitivity. So we've wondered, well, how do cells actually
control this? Can we toggle this on and off at will and
prime the tumor cells to take up our
drug of interest? So we, of course, initially looked at the three
luminal defining transcription factors in bladder cancer.
These are GATA3, FOXA1, and PPARy.
And amongst these three transcription factors, we were very interested in PPARy.
And that's primarily because, of course, PPARy is a nuclear
hormone receptor whose ligand is made up of
prostaglandins and leukotrienes, and it can also be modulated by fatty
acids in the diet.
PPARy is also the target of drugs that we
know already, old drugs like rosiglitazone and pioglitazone,
which are used in diabetes that can agonize the pathway.
And now there are actually inverse agonists that are generated, a tool compound
called T007, and then one by Flare Therapeutics called FX-909.
And what this nuclear hormone receptor does is that upon binding prostaglandins and
leukotrienes, it binds to its heterodimer, RXR, a
retinoid receptor, which we'll talk about in just a few slides, and drives
transcription of its target genes.
So what happens when we add rosiglitazone into the bladder
cancer cells? Well, we see upregulation of nectin-4.
And if we inversely agonize the PPARy pathway, we see a downregulation.
We see that at the protein level, we get a very nice dose response
to rosiglitazone
that's not only inside the cell, but also on the surface of the cell.
To a certain extent, this is actually specific.
We're not completely remodeling the surfaceome, because if we take a look at
Trop-2, another target that Dr. Ellison just talked about, we don't see
induction of Trop-2, but we do see induction of nectin-4.
And to a certain extent also, it's specific to the PPARy and not to the PPARa
pathway. If we use a tool compound from BMS, you can see that there's no
induction of nectin-4. And in fact, if we just add arachidonic
acid, a polyunsaturated fatty acid, into the cell culture media, we can actually
get this really nice induction of this low-expressing cell line
to express more nectin-4 on the cell surface here.
So can we actually leverage this and improve killing?
And so what we've done is we've taken this prime then treat strategy
to prime the cells to induce nectin-4 expression, particularly in the
low-expressing tumor, and then add the ADC into the culture.
And what we can see is that in the primed cells, here shown in
blue, we see a dramatic suppression of tumor growth compared to just
adding the EV alone. And what I'll mention is that the priming step only
takes two days, and then we take off the primer,
right? And
because the antibody drug conjugate is already bound and then will get
internalized. Can we generalize this concept to other surface targeting
therapies? Well, we also generated a nectin-4 CAR T cell to essentially show the
same thing. If you prime the tumor cell with rosiglitazone, here in orange,
you can see a very dramatic cell kill compared to your control cells.
And of course, we wanted to know, is this actually just potentiating an allogeneic
effect because the CARs are not matched with our target cells?
And in fact, we aren't, right? So there is specificity to the target
that we're looking at. We can show this in multiple different E to T ratios and, of
course, also see induction of interferon gamma, TNF-alpha, all
the sort of players that you would expect here.
So does priming with rosiglitazone, will that actually increase toxicity?
I think that's one of the key questions.
And to really think about this a little bit, what we did is we
turned to the GTEx database and looked at nectin-4 and PPARy
expression in normal tissues. And what you'll see is that tissues that have
highHigh levels of PPAR gamma generally have very low levels of
neptin-4 and vice versa. Those that have high levels of neptin-4, and
particularly the skin toxicity is an issue with neptin-4 targeting therapies,
have very low levels of PPAR gamma.
So we think that's where our therapeutic window is going to lie in.
And then, of course, bladder cancers are the ones that actually co-express both
of these proteins. So we don't think we're turning on, if we had to borrow
analogy from your radio, we don't think we're going to be able to turn on the
power switch, but we're going to be able to turn up the volume.
And so we've now tested this in normal bladder epithelial cells and
keratinocytes, where we've added rosiglitazone using the exact same priming
step. We don't see a dramatic induction of neptin-4.
And in fact, when we add the ADC or the CAR, we do not see more
killing of these normal cells. So suggesting that maybe we will
be able to prime the tumor specifically without increasing
toxicity. So what else regulates neptin-4?
So, I showed you that we were first just making a hypothesis and a guess
of
what the regulators are. We've now conducted a CRISPR screen, and
again, this is work really led by Tamila Nechiporuk and Carissa Chu's
lab, where we've taken sorted cells with high and low
expressing neptin-4 after infecting with a CRISPRi
library. And what we can see, number one, is that our screen works.
Neptin-4 comes out on the correct side of the volcano plot, and a number of
these genes actually lie in this luminal basal
differentiation pathway, sort of like what we expected based on what we had
seen from the correlative data.
The target I'll talk to you a little bit more about today is this really exciting
target called STRA6. And what STRA6 is, it's actually a parallel
pathway. It actually regulates retinoic acid signaling via vitamin
A. It's a critical transporter of vitamin A into the
cells. And similarly to PPAR gamma, also binds to the
RXR heterodimer to drive transcription of
retinoic acid target genes. Now, some of you may recognize
retinoic acid because, of course, we also have small molecules that can perturb
this pathway. So all-trans retinoic acid or ATRA, which is actually used for
APML patients to induce differentiation, as well as nine-cis retinoic
acid, Bexarotene, can actually be used to
modulate this pathway. And so just to formally demonstrate here, if
we knock down STRA6 using our CRISPR interference or CRISPR knockout
systems, you can see here in purple that the amount of neptin-4 goes down, shifts
to the left compared to the blue control cells.
So what happens when we add ATRA or Bex?
You can see again this very nice induction of neptin-4 expression,
and we can now shift that IC50 curve to the left by,
again, pre-treating with these retinoids.
So we think we have multiple different ways of dealing with patients
with low-expressing tumors, what we might think of
primary resistance, but how about acquired resistance?
So to do this, we've actually generated
multiple different cell lines through serially passaging cells in escalating
concentrations of EV. And what you can see here is in vitro, we get this really
nice shift to the right with an IC50 shift at about fivefold.
We've also validated that these in vitro generated EV-resistant cells
are, in fact, resistant to EV when we
subcutaneously implant them in mice.
And what happens to neptin-4 expression?
So what was surprising to us here was that in these EV-resistant cell lines,
we did not see downregulation of neptin-4.
And in fact, we actually saw upregulation of neptin-4 in
these cell lines. And we were very puzzled by this.
What we thought, and probably what Sarat might tell us next, is
that for many of the ADCs,
downregulation is a common mechanism of resistance.
What Carissa did when she was a fellow at MSK, along with David Solid and
Hikmat Alammardi, was biopsy pre- and
post-EV patients. And again, what we saw was that the majority of
these patients actually had upregulation of neptin-4 at the time of
resistance. So we've actually wondered, well, how do we actually
combat resistance? And I think a lot of this is payload
that Dr. Ellison also mentioned, but we wondered whether there was some problem
with the neptin-4 protein. So for those of you who know a little bit about
different surface proteins, they are oftentimes proteolyzed in the extracellular
space, and so maybe the binder is just unable to bind to the protein.
And many of these antibodies actually target the C-terminal
non-glycosylated portions of the protein.
So maybe we're getting an artifact here.
So what we did was we took the EV binder and cloned it into our CAR construct, our
CAR backbone, and we asked, do these CARs actually still
have activity against these EV-resistant cells?
And what you can see is that, again, these EV-resistant cells on the bottom
are in fact resistant to very high concentrations of EV, but they're
actually equally sensitive to the parental cells, to
the CAR. And so what this suggests to us is that at the time of resistance
to EV, there's going to be probably a subset of patients who
we can change modalities against the same target.
And I think this is something that a lot of us in the field are thinking about in
terms of how do we sequence, how do we combine these different surface
protein targeting therapies?
And I'll just say that in some cases, obviously, it's very
heterogeneous, and I think that's one of the big challenges.
In some of our cell lines, again, here showing you the EV-resistant cells that are
on the bottom, they're actually resistant to the payload, MMAE.
And so we need to think about
mechanisms like P-glycoprotein expression, MDR1 expression, and I think there's a
couple of really nice posters presented at the meeting here looking at
that protein. And, of course, looking at receptor trafficking.
So in that cell line that was EV resistant, that had very high levels of neptin-4,
we actually see that there's a change in the endosomal flux
of the ADC. So this is using a pH-sensitive fluorescent dye, a photo dye, and
we could actually see the EV-resistant cells take up the antibody much
less frequently. So how can we actually perturb and modulate the
lysosome internalization machinery here, I think is really interesting.
And of course, there's a lot of heterogeneity in the process.
I showed you one example of the EV-resistant cell lines.
We've single-cell cloned and generated a bunch, and you can actually just see a lot
of different heterogeneity. And I think what this really speaks to is that we
really need to re-biopsy patients at the time of resistance or
develop and validate non-invasive methods to measure the
target of expression, your favorite target of interest, whether it's through PET
imaging or ctDNA using fragmentomics or methylation ctDNA, to
really try to understand what is going on.
And finally, what I'll just share with you is our little bit of data using
spatial to
look at patients who progress on EV, and I think this is really interesting because
it actually piggybacks really nicely off of Dr. Ellison's talk.
And we actually find that for EV, the patients who are actually
responding really well have an interesting CD4 Treg
phenotype here that's associated, and this is actually work done by Brendan Raizen
and
Franklin Huang. So much more to come, I think, to think about what these other cell
types are doing in the tumor microenvironment and
really to understand whether these different cells are actually playing a causal
role. This is all correlative data.
We really need to figure out how do we actually demonstrate, can we perturb these
populations and actually demonstrate an enhanced benefit?
So with that, my conclusion slide, I hope to have shown you that
response to EV, at least in the upfront setting, is dependent on neptin-4
expression. Those with very high expression
or amplifications have very good responses to EV.
Maybe this is a population that we can actually think about deescalating therapy,
too. For those who have low neptin-4 expression, which may be a primary
marker of resistance, we actually now have two different pathways that we
might be able to pull on the toggles to induce expression to try to
enhance activity.Really this prime then treat type of strategy.
We've shown that there's a very heterogeneous response to
resistance, some losing expression, some retaining expression, but
being resistant to the payload or changing lysosomal dynamics.
And I think at the end of the day, these resistance mechanisms are going to be
complex, and we really do need to study this and in our patients, to really
think about what the appropriate next step is going to be.
And really, I think we've just scratched the surface in terms of thinking about how
these other immune cells, CAFs,
endothelial cells that we just heard about, how do they actually interact with the
ADCs? Are they secreting soluble factors, cell-cell
factors, other stromal factors that we can use, perturb, and target?
So with that, I'd like to thank the many people who I've had the really lucky
chance and privilege to work with, in particular, my good friend and colleague,
Carissa Chu, who's also here, as well as Tamila and Kevin Chang.
Thank you to my funding sources, and I'd be happy to take questions. Thank you.
All right. We have a few minutes for questions. Please come to the microphones.
If you don't mind, I'll start.
I'm wondering,
do you note the extent to which pre-treatment,
the transcriptional activity of PPARγ and retinoic acid is
actually responsible for high expression versus
low expression?
Yeah, that's a great question.
We are going through our pre-treatment biopsies to look for those
signatures right now. And I think
whether or not
we see it, I think it still doesn't mean that we can't act on that
pathway-
Got you
... whether it's through retinol or PPARγ.
So I think super interesting question in terms of thinking about
biomarker selection. But I really think that what we need to do is perturb the
pathway and really try to understand whether or not we can make a rational
combination therapy there.
Great. So over here on the right.
Yes. Thank you for a great presentation.
I was wondering about nectin-4, if it's known what it does
for the tumor cells. Is there a risk
of
giving the tumor cells an advantage just to be able to knock them down with an ADC?
Yeah, that's a great question. So in our cell line studies,
where we've either knocked out or overexpressed nectin-4, we see no change
in terms of cell proliferation or tumor growth in
preclinical animal models. I think one of the
key points here is that we are priming the target, whether or not the
target actually ends up conferring a survival advantage or disadvantage.
We think that we're just priming the target to soak up whatever
nectin-4 ADC or nectin-4 targeting therapy that
you have in mind. And so it's a transient thing, right?
So we pre-treat and then we give the drug.
We
think that this strategy can be generally applicable whether or not you're
inducing, for example, like HER2 might be an example, or maybe you
might be a little bit more hesitant to induce HER2 expression, knowing that it has
a oncogenic role in bladder cancer and breast cancer.
But again, I think that this is a transient expression, so I think we might
be able to get away with it, but of course, I don't have the data to back that up.
Thank you.
Last number on the left.
Thank you for the great presentation.
It's quite exciting to see that with the PPARγ agonist and the
retinoic acid agonist, you can increase the expression of the nectin-4.
So if you are trying to translate it to the clinic, how do you think that the
clinical trial will be done or the treatment also of the patient?
Yeah, I think that's a great question in thinking about how to design this trial.
And I'm not a trialist,
even though I do take care of patients and put people on trial.
We've talked about a number of different things, whether or not we can just use
off-label, essentially. Rosiglitazone is a very, very cheap drug, and design a
trial to look at what the ORR is going to be,
and compare it to the monotherapy population.
We've also talked about, oh, can we put people on like high carrot diets,
right? Just give them a lot of vitamin A and give them carrot
juice and will that actually work?
We've actually been trying to play around with
that concept in mice models. But I think the
most straightforward is going to be to give it as an
adjunct to standard of care EV. So pre-treating with
rosiglitazone or with ATRA or the combination and then taking a
look at what the response rate is. I think we also need to have a lot of PK/PD sort
of
correlatives built in to actually know whether we're hitting the target and whether
or not we can see upregulation of an expression.
The last thing I'll say is that nectin-4 is actually cleaved, and you
can detect
a soluble form of nectin-4 in the blood.
So whether or not we can use an ELISA to do non-invasive
monitoring of our induction is something we've been thinking about.
Last question. Is it specific only to the PPARγ?
Also alpha and delta can also do the same job.
We think it's only to PPARγ.
Specific?
Yeah.
Thank you.
All right. Nothing online. So let's thank our speaker again.
Terrific.
All right. So,
as evident from my title, I'm going to really focus in then on the
HER2 ADCs in my presentation, focusing
mainly on breast cancer and again, thinking about why is
it that this blockbuster efficacy of trastuzumab
deruxtecan gets abrogated in the resistant setting.
These are my disclosures, and they're available at the ASCO
website. So as it was just stated, I think it's
sort of captain obvious here, but it's important to remind us that HER2,
as a target for an ADC, is a little distinct in that unlike
many other ADC targets, it is a bona
fide oncogenic driver.
And whether it is amplified or if it has
mutations that activate its kinase activity,
this confers-... extreme oncogenic
potency.
And therefore,
not only does that have an influence on the way in which the ADC
works, right? So to the degree to which the antibody is having some sort
of signaling effect independent of the payload.
Secondly, it is very hard for a cancer
at resistance to lose its driver. This would
not typically be a preferred way in which resistance
occurs, is to lose the oncogenic driver
without replacing it. So for HER2 amplified
breast cancer and other cancers where its amplification confers
driver status,
as well as for HER2 mutant cancers, I think this
influences strongly the
anticipated resistance patterns that we might see.
And so I can come back to that in a little bit.
But I want to really start with that because I think it lays a foundation for
something that's distinct when we think about HER2 ADCs.
All right. So getting right to what we have seen in looking at
resistance to NHER2 in breast cancer.
We initially just tried to do genomic profiling of
post-T-DXd resistance cases, shown here again in a
very small series
led by my colleague Josh Drago on the breast
medicine service at MSK.
We identified a couple of alterations
specifically in HER2
that came up at resistance. Most of the things, and we looked at the
profiles by next generation sequencing, pre-treatment and post-treatment were
identical. So just a few cases where we saw things that were
distinct, at least in terms of DNA sequencing.
And importantly, we identified a couple of cases where there were point
mutations in HER2, but were not
classic activating
mutations in HER2. So what were these mutations?
Shown here, when we mapped the mutations onto the known crystal
structure of trastuzumab bound to HER2,
these mutations were identified within
the known interaction site between trastuzumab and the switch
II for region of HER2. Computational
modeling indeed suggested that these would
interfere with avid binding of
trastuzumab.
So a graduate student in my lab, Wanyi Chen,
took up looking at this issue, asking what was the implication of
this mutation on whether or not
HER2 ADCs could work on the cell. So she set
up a simple system where she overexpressed either wild type HER2 or
the mutant copy,
and achieved similar levels of expression at the cell surface of
these two,
and looked at internalization of T-DXd.
And while the wild type certainly induced T-DXd really well in
this internalization assay was described earlier,
we did not see much internalization with the mutant.
Importantly, this translated then to the efficacy in
vitro of T-DXd in terms of killing cells.
We see that the wild type
overexpression conferred sensitivity to T-DXd,
while the mutant did not.
And that translated to a significant difference in the IC50 for
these two different models.
So this is just a second case. In this case, it was a case of acquired
HER2 mutation in a case that was already HER2 mutant.
So this case had an activating HER2 mutant, had really
strong benefit from T-DXd,
and then acquired a mutation again in the exact same region.
That identical data essentially
computationally interfered with
predicted avid binding, and that translated to all the same sort of
things I showed you with the cell line.
So these are rare, and I think that the reason I highlight
them is that they demonstrate the principle
that interfering with avid binding has the
potential to reduce internalization, has the potential to
reduce the full effect of T-DXd in these
models. And I think that's similar to what Leif
presented at the beginning with an example of a
TROP2 mutation that changed,
in that case, the cell surface abundance.
I think this illustrates the importance of the
high abundance on the cell surface for this antibody drug
conjugate having maximal efficacy.
All right. So that describes point mutations which are rare.
And one of the reasons why we think it would be pretty rare for a HER2
amplified breast cancer to acquire such a mutation is that there are
many copies of HER2, so it would be hard to mutate that same
allele multiple times, right?
Instead, we
don't
see a lot of alterations in HER2 overexpressing cancers.
But when we look in the second indication for T-DXd, and that's in
HER2 low cancers that express some level of HER2, we do
see losses in expression,
either downregulation of HER2 at a modest level or complete
loss of HER2 in a significant number of cases.
So
we are seeing acquired loss of HER2, particularly in HER2
low cancers. Now, as
I'm indicating, HER2 low is an indication for the drug,
so it's a little bit counterintuitive to think that
low expression could be contributing to resistance.
I think it's important to remember that similar to what Jonathan talked about,
the fact thatAn ADC beat chemotherapy doesn't mean that
the level of expression is irrelevant to the
maximal efficacy, nor that it's
irrelevant to
maintaining that activity. That is, drug resistance could still occur
through loss of expression. But to prove that,
we set out again to set up models where we could down-regulate expression
of HER2, leave everything else the same, and see what
that did to sensitivity to the drug.
And so Wanyi, again, set up this system.
She did it in multiple models where she could lower expression of HER2
using a doxycycline-inducible promoter.
That led to stable levels of HER2 at these
different level concentrations of
doxycycline. And
so again, she used multiple assays to show that lowering HER2
levels at the cell surface in this model lowered how much
TDxd was internalized in the cell.
Again, different levels of dox, different levels of internalization.
Importantly, if you go from a relatively high to zero, you really
have very little internalization at that point.
Similar data, if you look in a different assay here, we're looking at
levels of HER2 by
confocal microscopy for tracking TDxd.
You can see internally lysosomal HER2 here,
and a lack when there is a lack of doxycycline,
that is lower HER2 expression.
All right, so we see lowering HER2 expression means less drug gets
in.
What does that do, again, to the effect of the drug?
Again, the effect of the drug is suppressed.
We see a lot more cells when there is low HER2 expression
than when there's high HER2 expression.
And if you look at the IC50, I would just say that this is a
substantial change in the IC50. We're talking about an
800-fold change in IC50 in these cells.
That is the exact same kind of concentration difference
that we see for chemotherapies that work or don't work, targeted
therapies that work or don't work.
So we're really seeing meaningful differences in the
potency of the drug based on lowering HER2 expression.
This was true in a number of models, and I won't go through it as this is
published. But what this led to for us was the idea
that if you went up front,
what you're really trying to get is you're trying to get Dxd maximally
into the cell. And so why are we restricting ourselves just to
HER2? What if we could come in with a second
way of bringing in Dxd?
And so,
we do have approval for a Trop2 ADC with
Dxd. Why not try a combination of Trop2 with
HER2? And testing this just in the cell
line models, we do see that low concentrations of a HER2 ADC
given with low concentrations of a Trop2 ADC together
are as good as where a high concentration of either
alone. And that was true in vitro, and we could see these effects in vivo.
And importantly, if we measure Dxd levels in the tumor after
we co-administer low levels of the drug, we get this
really impressive amount of Dxd in the tumor.
I think what this tells us is that these are independent
pathways,
that they're not tied to the exact same rate-limiting step for bringing the
drug in. HER2 and Dxd are not interacting at the cell surface in such a
way that it's all rate limited or bottlenecked by the same
process. You can bring in Dxd through independent portals.
And so to the degree to which we think that some of these cell
surface targets are in very distinct
compartments of the cell surface, they're regulated by different internalization
machinery. They may represent targets that we could
co-target at the same time,
and
potentially lower the effective dose of the drug
by giving it as a combination.
So we are trying to test this concept now.
Nick May, an investigator at our institution, is leading a clinical trial where
we're combining these, and I think really trying to help us to think, why are we
giving the drugs in this sort of sequential way, sort of waiting for resistance and
then potentially giving it? Could we do this as an upfront
strategy to maximally
increase the amount of Dxd? The second point I want to conclude
from this is just to say, the way that we might want to think about
resistance to these drugs is, how much ultimate
AUC of Dxd do you get, right? It's how much you get in, how much
you take out.
That really translates to complete response versus not.
And so whether that's due to the internalization process or whether that's due to
drug pumps, ultimately payload resistance may be because of
target-mediated effects or effects on
cells extrinsic to the actual drug binding
of topoisomerase and DNA.
All right, so part one has really been about how we see
alterations in the target itself that potentially are relevant
to resistance. What about adjacencies?
Is there anything relevant to these multi-protein
complexes that these cell surface targets are part of
that are important as well in mediating resistance?
And so
to look at this question of the adjacencies,
I turn to an example where we were looking
at the obvious adjacency to HER2, and that is
its binding partner. So HER2 does not exist as a monomer.
It is an obligate dimer. It exists as
heterodimers with other EGF family receptors like EGFR,
HER3, and HER4, or as a homodimer. And in certain cancer types,
we see an abundance of those
other heterodimer partners like EGFR.
We looked in that context in EGFR and HER2 high cells.
And in those that have very high levels of EGFR, we do
actually see an association of lower internalization of
TDxd. So this is not affecting how much HER2 there is, but
it is affecting its partner.All right, so was that
relevant? Was that actually causal?
So Avantika Gupta, a postdoc in the lab,
did a simple thing. She overexpressed EGFR in a cell that had low EGFR
and asked the question: What did that do to T-DXd response?
And she indeed found that overexpressing EGFR, while it didn't really affect
the tumor growth kinetics intrinsically, it did
confer partial resistance to the effects of
T-DXd.
How is it doing so? Again, we do see this association
of EGFR interacting with HER2 as
contributory to the way in which this worked.
Here, just looking at the levels of heterodimers versus
homodimers with proximity ligation assays,
she found that overexpression of EGFR led to increases in
interactions between EGFR and HER2, and concomitant decreases in
HER2, HER2 homodimers in the model.
So this led us to the idea that we could potentially perturb
this and have an effect. Again, not touching HER2, how
could we affect its binding partners and influence
drug response?
So either using genetic mechanisms to knock down
EGFR or pharmacologic strategies to target EGFR,
could we affect this internalization process?
So shown here,
we utilized cetuximab as an antibody that induces EGFR
internalization,
as well as kinase inhibitors that do and hit HER2 or
EGFR, lapatinib, neratinib.
And found that
there was the
capacity for EGFR antibodies to actually
increase the amount of internalization of T-DXd.
Similarly, knockdown of EGFR could have that effect.
So by stimulating EGFR, the partner, we could actually
see an increase in HER2 internalization.
Doing some microscopy where we labeled
T-DXd and EGFR, we could see this little
tiny yellow and red dot going into the cell
after administration. And so we would see these little puncti of
together EGFR receptor bound
with cetuximab and HER2 bound with T-DXd going in
together at the same time in the cells rather than these independent events,
suggesting to us that it's really due to this heterodimer complex that is
being internalized.
So could this translate to a therapeutic benefit?
So we tested the combination of EGFR antibody together with
T-DXd,
using cetuximab.
We could see increases again in internalization in multiple models.
And
we saw in vivo the combination of
cetuximab with T-DXd potentially converting stable
disease/progressive disease to substantial
responses in some cases,
like these two are fairly impressive.
In this case,
modest additivity. But again, some of these cases, cetuximab by
itself is having very little anti-tumor effect
by itself. So I think consistent with the idea that there could
be this
ability to perturb the T-DXd internalization
process through its binding partner.
We could see this in other EGFR overexpressing HER2
high models
like head and neck cancer and
a model of glioblastoma and gastric cancer.
So we have now converted this data into a
clinical trial led by my colleague Rona Yager, where we're treating
patients in colorectal cancer that is HER2 high together
with cetuximab, which, of course, is already an
approved drug. But these are in patients who have already progressed on that.
And trying to see to what degree and in which
cancers or what
sort of other factors dictate
when this combination might be beneficial.
So hopefully more to come on that soon.
Finally, as was alluded to by my colleagues and
we want to move beyond the known entities.
We want to understand at a broad level what else might be influential
in T-DXd responses. So we need to move beyond these single
readouts of just looking at HER2 or just looking at EGFR and
profiling a little more broadly what are these factors that are
mediating sensitivity and resistance.
And so
trying to take our pretreatment, post-treatment samples and ask by
multiplex assays, in this case immunofluorescence, what's happening at
resistance? This is just emblematic of the fact that I think spatial
technologies are going to be really helpful in these cases.
Again, as was already mentioned, I think here we're seeing
regions of loss of HER2 across the tumor.
So it's not as though all of the progressive disease has losses of
HER2, but certain regions do.
And those may be regions that have expression of other targets.
What we're also, of course, trying to do is have more unbiased and broader
profiling, and so doing both multiplex immunofluorescence
together with spatial transcriptomics.
And so this is a collaboration with
a computational oncologist, Saurabh Sha, to try to interpret this complex data
and ask,
what are happening in these different progressive regions in the cancer?
How can we interpret that as actually contributory
to resistance or just bystanders?
And so
this is... ongoing work to try to take these
complex data, integrate them together, and ask the question: What is it
that is actually happening in these cell populations?
This is just a cool video, but what we're really trying to get at, again,
are there specific
molecular bases for how these pockets of resistance are
emerging? And what we're seeing in these
are interesting transcriptional signatures of
resistance that are emerging within these pockets.
So more than just is HER2 loss or not, but what else
is driving the cancer in those cases potentially, and what else
might represent targets? Don't have any answers on large numbers, just trying to
say that I think that as a field, we're going to need to, of course, try to grapple
with this kind of data going forward.
So just
on the second part,
I think that what we've observed is that the proteins interacting with the antibody
drug target can also influence this process of
internalization and drug sensitivity.
It may be the partner, it may be part of the machinery that internalizes, and there
have been other data sets that have suggested that internalization
also is subject to potentially alterations that
mitigate drug response.
And I think going forward,
all of us are really thinking about ways in which the cells and the
neighboring
cells and neighboring proteins to the ADC target can evolve and
serve as new mechanisms
of resistance, but also anchors for our therapies.
With that, I've tried to highlight the people in the lab.
I just want to mention our collaborators and funders who've supported this work,
and thank you for your attention and questions.
Can I start, Sarot?
Yeah.
I'm sure you've said it, but is the EGFR association
predicted by the amount of HER2 or amplification of HER2?
And is it restricted to amplified, or is it associated-
Yeah.
-with HER2 low as well?
Good question. So
real question is do you need essentially high levels of HER2 in the get go?
And the answer is yes. You do need that anchor of HER2 being relatively high, and
we don't really see it in very low HER2 cells.
So here and then over here. So start here.
Yeah. So really fascinating. So you got me thinking
when you were showing the dato-DXd plus
T-DXd approach, and you made the comment about trying to increase
the area under the curve intra-tumorally.
Yeah.
So you know, at this meeting, there seems to be a ton of bispecific
antibodies.
Mm-hmm.
So would a
Trop2/HER2 bispecific that delivers a
topo1 clinically be more impactful, or do you
think a lower dose of these approved
ADCs or soon-to-be-approved ADCs
co-administration? Because you started off the meeting by saying-
Yeah
... "Look, there's a lot of this stuff going on, and you have to focus on ADC
mechanisms of resistance."
Yeah.
So that's
question number one.
Yep.
Question number two would be,
are these topo inhibitors created equal?
Is
what SG delivers as an SN 38 the same
as
deruxtecan, the same as exatecan?
So two questions.
Okay.
Low dose combos in the clinic?
Yeah. So I think
we would have to just empirically understand
whether bispecifics versus
biparatropics or trying to just have independent antibodies is a
better approach.
As it is, I think that each antibody, in the way that it's designed
and where it binds on the
antigen,
actually influences how good of an internalizer it is.
Certain antibodies are poor internalizers, some are good,
some are better. So I think that's also baked into the question.
So there is a bit of a more of empirical sort of, we think we have to try it to
see. But I do want to just emphasize the idea that at least as concepts,
I do think that these are not all tied to the same internalization
process. And so if we were just reimagining how we were
developing these drugs based on,
not that we have to get an approval for a
single drug, but just how could we give it to our patients?
I don't know if we would design it the same way.
Why wouldn't we give it as a cocktail? Is there a reason for that?
Or at least to test it de novo.
Second question was on the potency and the
comparability of the actual payloads.
There have been studies to suggest that having a more potent
topo inhibitor could be better. There was a publication on
exatecan versus deruxtecan that suggested
that that actually could overcome resistance because of higher potency
and less being subject to the same drug pump
mechanisms.
We haven't necessarily had a clear clinical demonstration of that either.
So the one distinction I would make in trying to draw a comparison
between, say, deruxtecan and SN 38, that is
SG and dato-DXd, is just that not only are
those subtle differences in the payload, but there are linker differences as well,
and that probably does contribute in an important
way. So hard to make that comparison from the clinical data.
Thank you.
Going to go here next. Yeah.
Hello. Very beautiful work. I just wonder,
based on the clinical trial that destiny showed that HER2
low or ultra low, they all very respond well to
the
T-DXd. So I just wonder, other than the internalization
or EGFR in related mechanism, have you thought about the
bystander effect, like relate to immune cell,
how that, because it also affect the
response and the resistance, right?
Yeah, I think that there's no question there are aspects of the
construct, whether it's the half-life of the drug,
whether it's the fact that there's any HER2 expression, whether it's
some effect of Herceptin
that is contributing to the overall effect.
So
no question, HER2 lows, very lows can respond to the drug.
Loss of that, however, diminishes the full benefit is, I
think what we're trying to say. But, and one of the things that your point
is well taken about is we haven't really talked a lot about ways in which we
see resistance emerging through the actual
immune effector part, which I think is likely to be there and likely to be
important, particularly in combinations with PDL1.
So I think we have
a long way to go in terms of figuring out the full suite of potential
mechanisms of resistance.
Yeah, exactly right. It is not necessary to be internalized, right?
Because
the ultra low population responds very well.
Yeah. I think you can have response.
I think it's better to be internalized than to be internalized a lot.
That's how I'll put it. Back here.
I want to thank you and all the speakers for this really great session.
And implied and demonstrated in a couple of
instances is the different
mechanisms of resistance that can arise in the same patient.
So my first question is: Do we believe that that is
common and maybe even the majority in patients
who do progress on these cancers, that there's many mechanisms that
apply?
And if so, how we think about overcoming multiple
resistance mechanisms therapeutically. Thank you.
Yeah. And I'll let Leif, I think, has that seminal example, so he can
comment as well. One of the challenges here, of course, is
many of the assays that we are trying to understand require
tissue biopsy. How good liquid biopsy is going to be at
defining some of this,
I think remains to be seen. I don't think we can reliably look at expression levels
with current assays.
There may be new technologies allow us to do so.
But yeah, I think, at autopsy, yes, you can
profile these different mechanisms, but harder to do when you're
making clinical decisions. So we honestly don't know.
I think the case does point to the possibility.
One of the things I
can say is that there are different patterns in which we see clinical
resistance emerging, right? We see oligo progression in some patients.
We see
massive progression of multiple sites in other cases.
And I think it's more likely that in these sort of oligo progressive
cases, we can potentially understand singular mechanisms of
resistance in those. But
I think we need new modalities to study for your question.
I don't know if you have anything to add, Leif.
Yeah, I guess I think the only thing I would add is that we think about all the
ways that tumor heterogeneity increases in the metastatic
process, and that can give rise to these sort of things that we saw, which
were multiple tumor intrinsic mechanisms.
To the extent that the immune system also plays a role in resistance, the idea
that, for example, different metastatic sites with different immune
microenvironments might be kind of sowing the seeds for
different types of resistance is also something we have to consider.
So I think that's going to continue to be an ongoing challenge and in
some ways does speak to the potential benefits of
multiple targeting, targeting through multiple axes through combinations.
Thank you very much.
Marson, last question.
Hi, how are you? So I'm interested in these HER2 low
resistance mechanisms. Is that a genomically
driven loss of expression? And I know there's been some questions about
whether ADCs work through a non-target effect there.
So in some ways, are you proving that that's actually the case, but how
frequently does that happen? And presumably these tumors aren't HER2
addicted. Is it an issue of how they're being classified originally
by IHC? There's obviously-
Yeah, good. So we don't see genomic
losses like complete
copy
loss or frank... We actually have one example, I
think, of a stop mutation. But we don't see a lot of genomic losses in HER2
in these HER2 low cases that have...
So we were seeing it more at an RNA expression level.
Deletions or...
Yeah. Not a lot of them, at least to the degree that we've
profiled.
All right. If there are other questions, I think
Spio's will be up here for a bit, so
just want to thank the other speakers and all of you for your engagement.